david if joe biden gets elected
and democrats take the senate what will
democrats actually get done
so first of all if biden wins and
democrats take the senate
it's a two-year period okay democrats
could then lose the senate in 2022 or
lose the house we don't know
there's the low-hanging fruit and then
there's the more complicated stuff so
certainly joe biden will have no choice
but to use executive orders to undo a
ton of trump's executive orders now
fortunately many of trump's executive
orders were just symbolic in nature
they didn't really do much but a lot of
executive orders will be needed to stop
the damage of trump's executive orders
that do
things i do think that relatively
quickly
a democratic senate and joe biden would
move to try to undo
as much as possible of donald trump's
tax reform plan
that included handouts to the very rich
and even provisions that allow donald
trump to extend his tax loss carry
forwards indefinitely rather than just
10 or 18 years however much it was
but there's a really big question here
which is that
republicans now i mean listen they
stopped merit garland in 2016
and now they will probably succeed at
putting in amy coney barrett
they don't care about hypocrisy they
will obstruct they will do whatever
democrats if they win the senate and joe
biden wins
are going to have to grapple with what
to do about the filibuster
the filibuster which requires 60 senate
votes instead of a simple majority
to get a lot of things done and i don't
think we are going to see major
legislative action
if republicans really suffer an
embarrassing defeat where trump has made
a one-term president which is rare in
american politics
and if republicans lose the senate
they're going to be hurting and they
will get in the way of anything they can
i don't see obamacare being expanded the
way joe biden wants
without uh 60 votes and there's no way
that they're going to get 60 votes so
the question will be do they get rid of
the filibuster i don't see
joe biden's clean energy plan going
anywhere
if it depends on you know a senate that
is 52 to 48
in favor of democrats if that's what it
is so if democrats
take control over the senate and they
rewrite the filibuster rules
then you may see more action done now
are they going to do that
it's risky barack obama alluded to it at
the funeral of john lewis
that's probably the highest profile
support we've seen of getting rid of the
filibuster but
understand that whatever democrats
imagine that it takes i don't know 8 to
12 months of joe biden's first term
to get rid of the filibuster and then
democrats get something done
in the second year of joe biden's first
term
and then imagine that republicans take
back the senate
and maybe even the house we don't know
in 2022
you have opened the door for republicans
to use the lack of a filibuster
to do ungodly things so this is always
the question is it does it start a race
to the bottom
i don't know the answer but if somehow
democrats figured out a way to get the
votes i believe the priorities would be
deal with coronavirus relief in a more
serious manner
if depending on when that happens expand
obamacare
in the way that joe biden wants to do
new tax reform plan
clean energy those would be the four
that i see the most likely that
democrats would want to tackle
if given the opportunity again depending
on what degree of a majority
do they have in the senate or do they
get rid of the filibuster one last thing
without getting rid of the filibuster
democrats could
still get things done if they take the
senate even if it's only
you know 5149 5248
but they will have to concede a ton to
republicans
they will have to pass their bills
with these horrifying disgusting
amendments
that they put in there in order to get
some republican votes
is the country better off if that's what
they do
i don't know you've really got to look
at the specifics
we've got a great bonus show for you
today with producer pat ford we will be
back next week with
the regular show the bonus show and the
vice presidential debate is next week
kamala i think she's going to crush
crush crush mike pence
we'll see you next week if you're not a
member if you are a member
enjoy the bonus show coming up right
after this